so we got a billboard in times square it
is massive it is it's got two sides
and it reads taylor loren's doxxed at
libs of tick tock and we did this
because taylor lorenz a journalist for
the washington post wielded
institutional power like a cudgel to
target people that she did not like the
framing of the story she did that doxxed
libs of tic tac was libs of tic tac tick
tock was that libs of tick tock is bad
okay
now i think that reporting
is great we should know
what is the motivation behind libs of
tick tock and depending on who the
person is behind it maybe we should know
who they are turns out it was kind of a
random person so publishing the name
served nothing in the story so i am
critical of taylor lorenz for publishing
the name but think the reporting was
merited
taylor lorenz then released private home
information and work information of this
individual which i condemn taylor lorenz
then lied about it on tv and the
washington post lied about it so i said
okay you want to wield institutional
power against regular people or against
people you know people to cause harm i
can wield institutional power too so
with the help of jeremy boring co-ceo of
the daily wire and the daily wire crew
we got this billboard up very quickly so
we'll talk all about that story as well
as a whole bunch of other stuff the um
the top lawyer for twitter vijaya gaday
the person that i actually spoke with on
the joe rogan podcast
cried in a meeting
discussing elon musk's twitter takeover
so we have a whole lot to break down
there in terms of elon's uh takeover of
this you know of all the twitter stuff
and uh
joe biden
apparently they found uh daily daily
mail is saying there's 5.2 million
dollars in his income unaccounted for
makes you wonder about what he was doing
with those special private deals with
china and in ukraine so we'll talk all
about this plus ron desantis is killing
it he's raising massive amounts of money
so we're going to talk about media
a lot of stuff having to do with elon
musk and the billboard stuff and the
aftermath of what's going on in terms of
doxxing so should be a good time joining
us to discuss this is derek harvey hey
glad to be here you want to pull your
mic up a little bit yeah sure uh tell us
who are you good sir well i'm derek
harvey i used to work for devin nunes as
the lead investigator for the house
intelligence committee i was in the army
for 26 years and chief of intelligence
for
general petraeus and general ordierno
served almost five years in iraq
and i was the special assistant and
director for middle east policy and
north africa policy for president trump
in the first year of the trump white
house wow
so storied career and now you're running
for office uh just right here in
maryland right right here in the county
you're in washington county i'm running
for the county commissioner position
and i think that we need some new
leadership new change i think i have the
experience
and the knowledge and the integrity to
bring
some changes to washington county this
is going to be great because not only do
we have to talk about stuff going on
behind the scenes with the white house
and uh the russia gate hoax and
corruption and media but as as someone
who lives in and is running in
washington county we can talk all about
why the failed policies that we see in
states like maryland result in
businesses fleeing which hurt those
states so that's going to be a lot of
fun thanks for joining us
absolutely we have sheamus yeah and i
just want to say i'm really interested
and exciting to hear some details about
the trump white house from an insider
i'm sure that's going to be fascinating
i'm seamus coughlin i run a channel
called freedom tunes we upload political
cartoons every single week every
thursday y'all should go subscribe if
you aren't already subscribed good to
see you derek i was like talking about
people that have military intelligence
experience i rolled in 84. oh that means
a big show
1984 all over again
oh geez 76 yesterday one baby yeah man
you know once one day at a time
peace and love and i am also here in the
corner pushing buttons as is my want
very excited to have derek he has a long
history and i'm soaked here what he's
got to say i also want to mention
there's one more story we're going to
talk about oh yeah something strange is
happening with the twitter algorithm
thanks for reminding me super chat we
have a few tweets pulled up tracking the
gain in followers among right-wing
personalities and the loss in followers
among left-wing personalities some have
said people are just coming back to the
platform and leftists are leaving i i
don't think that's true i absolutely not
tucker carlson didn't just gain 62 000
followers today
on news that broke yesterday morning
so that doesn't make sense many people
believe
this is twitter panicking and shutting
down their manipulation of the system
because elon musk is going to get in
there and he's going to see exactly what
they're doing and how much want to bet
malfeasance
and elon musk's going to have access to
all those records so they locked down
the code
well they supposedly locked down the
code defense sabotage but could it be
they lock down the code because they're
doing something nefarious behind the
scenes and don't want anyone to see it
we will see but let's uh before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support our work and
as a member not only do you get access
to exclusive segments of the tim cast
irl podcast monday through thursday at
8pm you help support us in doing things
like buying billboards
and in this instance with the help of
the daily wire they helped put this
together really really quickly so shout
out to jeremy bohr in the daily wire
this is uh
this
i i know i i said you know i wanted to
do this and i had a plan for it but they
had the magic and the institutional
force to push back and so i'm eternally
grateful for them but uh this is what
we're gonna do
as a member we are using
your membership fees to hire journalists
we just hire new we hire another
journalist we're going to hire two more
columnists really really soon we're
looking to hire uh some more house for
new shows we're expanding
that's thanks to you and we're going to
have fact checkers we've got a few
non-profits working on it's all about
building out the culture challenging the
machine and speaking truth to power but
let's talk about speaking truth to power
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
ladies and gentlemen i give you the
first story from timcast.com
tim cast ceo puts billboard in times
square calling out washington post
reporters doxxing of libs of tiktok
taylor lorenz blocked timpool on twitter
after videos of the sign were posted
online oh i want to talk about this so
bad now we do have a disclaimer at the
top it says tim poole is the owner and
ceo of timcast media including
timcast.com because we have standards
this seems a little biased i'm going to
be honest
actually it's
not it's a straightforward news story i
don't know i gotta look into it i'm not
gonna take your word for it i have you i
have tim cast ceo of tim cass telling me
his article on tim cast about him the
ceo of tim cast isn't biased are you
expecting to buy that right now it is
not bizarre all right well you see the
fact that we reveal that information
shows it's actually particularly
straightforward it's just several quotes
so a new message has joined the glowing
advertisements in new york city's times
square admonishing the washington post
for publishing private information of
the creator of libs of tick tock twitter
account it shows statements from me
it shows that you know very
straightforward jeremy bourne and and
tim cass put this together taylor loren
is a technology reporter for the
washington post it shows uh i believe uh
just statements from me mostly about it
now i suppose you can argue that taylor
her responses should have been included
in the story but considering it's just
about the billboard and why i did it i
think that's fair and i think it's fair
when i say you know this is how we're
addressing it what is it incredibly cool
and handsome ceo of tim cast
publishes awesome billboards
it also says super strong yeah yeah he's
really strong yeah and i won't take that
from you and his mom says he's the most
handsome that's true that's fair i think
the way this should have been framed is
bigoted far-right figure harass as a
poor innocent journalist
so let's let's let me tell you guys real
quick just about what happened
so we talked about putting up the
billboard we were like fingers crossed
they'll approve it they did all right i
think i will play for you the video
right here it's actually quite simple
it says
democracy dies in darkness
turn that down
that's why we're shining a light on you
taylor loren's doxed at libs of tick
tock
at tim cast so first let me just address
uh some of the immediate points people
brought up why didn't we link to
anything why didn't we use it as an
opportunity to promote the [ __ ] you
can't yeah you can't you cannot use
other people's likenesses to advertise
your product
so there are rules restrictions and laws
also
i'm like i have to sign it i'm the one
who did it i'm not going to pretend it
wasn't me
we're going to put tim cast on it what
else are we going to do i figured if we
didn't it would be i don't know i should
i should i should have my name on the
things that i'm doing so that's that's
ultimately how we decided to do it
the first thing that happens after we
put it up is taylor lorenz responded
saying
tim poole actually i think we might have
the the tweets from taylor lorenz as to
what she what she said maybe not okay
hold on no i don't think we do but uh
taylor lorenz responded that tim paul
the ceo of the daily wire put up this
billboard
trying to discredit my journalism my
response was
that i i didn't uh want to discredit her
journalism actually i defended her
reporting on libs of tick tock however
she lied about doxing and that's what
needed to be called out her response
was or so so let me let me show you this
image i said to her
uh when her response was like you know a
goofy face saying oh the internet's so
crazy i said i'm glad you and your
friends are happy you made your point on
cnn i made mine in times square and now
we can move on she responded my family
and friends are not happy they have been
subject to a non-stop stream of hateful
attacks doxxing and violent attacks
driven by this baseless campaign happy
to hear you're moving on taylor i did
not insult you i did not dox you and i
defended your reporting i called you a
liar because you lied about doxing libs
of tick tock if you do not want to be
held to account for for a moral or
unethical activities you should not be
in media committing a moral or unethical
activities i do not tolerate insulting
the person over over her appearance or
age i do not support doxing and i think
libs of tick tock should be reported on
we need to know who the influential
people behind our politics are
but when you lie about it you get called
out now she's claiming that there's
violent attacks and it's i'm part of
this campaign oh you know what just just
spare me words are violence remember
that words are violence that's where
we're at
yep no i mean look it's no secret this
podcast has been swatted a number of
times people here have been threatened i
also have had people harass me do things
that have made me feel unsafe i have
been doxxed i don't like saying it i
don't like talking about it it's a
little bit weird to bring it up every
single time someone criticizes you
yeah it's funny because she's like this
is violence against me and then she
posts it
like i don't i don't think you're being
serious you know you know i think
when the story first comes out i tweeted
the link
she tweets it with a goofy face saying
oh these people are so crazy oh this
post is so dumb
but then when i said glad you're not
upset and we can move on she lost it she
blocked me immediately then started then
she made another tweet saying this is
the violence behind this and now she's
acting like it's the big attack against
her no i think she likes the press
what's the evidence of violence i'd like
to explain that to everybody well see
we've talked about this before it's it's
it's it's a fascinating thesis
see um if you grow up or or grow up in
in hardship
or uh perhaps you're in the armed forces
you experience real risks and real
threats
when you are at risk of losing your life
from the job you're working
you know what violence really is when
you've been punched attacked or
assaulted you know what violence really
is but if you are a soft-bellied i don't
know let's say your family's rich and
they sent you to like a swiss boarding
school and so you've never really
experienced hardship well no one's ever
dared speak ill of you so the first time
someone says a nasty word you get that
shock to your system like someone
attacked you they feel physical pain
like
you you said what about me that's never
happened before she probably grew up
with participation awards and being told
she was great the whole time
yeah she went to a swiss boarding school
yeah
so
uh i can't imagine someone like her has
actually experienced hardship but i
think i i don't think she's um i don't
think she's stupid
certainly she understands that she docks
libs of tiktok and is lying about it
because it's seriously easily proven
it's now been confirmed by multiple
sources
that's why i pulled up other sources we
have this from the washington free
beacon which is my friend's news guard
certified which says lorenz not only
revealed the identity of the anonymous
person who runs the account but also
included a copy of the person's real
estate license which showed her home
address the post later removed the home
address from the story then lied about
it saying we did not publish or link to
any details about her personal life
let me just show you taylor lorenz's
wikipedia which says
the article further publicized the
identity of the account owner as chair
reichik and provided personal details
okay
so she's lying it's obvious she's lying
and she knows she's lying tim what's her
motivation for doing that because
by exposing that poor those personal
details it's inviting
harassment minimally it's inviting
violence
you're calling her out and you're giving
them the directions to where to go get
her yeah i think
look i'm not going to give taylor the
benefit of the doubt i think they
she or whoever on the team included the
link to the private address knowing what
they were doing to terrorize
because
you know we've got security issues we
know exactly what it means and we have
we have armed guards now we have to get
armed security in a variety of fashions
so when someone publishes your address
in one of the most powerful and largest
institutional publications in the world
even if it's for only an hour or two
you know what that means it means you're
not safe and because of that the person
behind libs of tick tock had to flee to
a safe location
now
it's possible that this is no longer the
current address of the individual all i
know and as we've reported
is that the address is listed in public
records as the private residence of the
individual
sometimes people have addresses listed
in public and they move from them and
never change it i think it's a fair
point to make because i want to make
sure everyone's getting as much
understanding of what's going on as
possible
taylor lorenz has not provided any
evidence or any counter claim other than
didn't do it it's like okay well well
here's the link it's in the archive
didn't do it
the washington post says they didn't
even link to it
well not you can actually just see the
link in the article in the archive yeah
and not only i didn't do it but you are
victimizing me by pointing out the fact
that i did it
correct
very slimy i i don't want to give them
the benefit of the doubt for putting
that up but i don't want to assume
intent either so i don't know exactly
why it all happened but here's the thing
so ian even if they didn't realize that
this person was going to be harassed and
potentially threatened and have their
safety put at risk when they published
their address
that would just make them incredibly
incompetent journalists who aren't
worthy of their platform so either way
it's horrible hey i agree with that yeah
massive failure regardless
it has to be called out yeah i'm kind of
like
geez go easy on this but no don't
because they really made a a
journalistic um faux pas or like like
massive mistake in in rendering you know
as little harm as possible to the people
that you're reporting on and that needs
to be called out so it doesn't happen
again well
they always cry foul when it's done to
them
when they're called out when they're
named you know they're a victim right
away
and
they did it to somebody else and they're
denying it and they always deny and then
they move on and they don't want to be
held accountable what's what's that uh
darvo is that what it's called
i don't know i've heard of durva or
something there's this thing they that
the left always says it's like deny
uh attack reverse victim and defender
yes oh so you reverse the victim and the
offender you don't know what she's doing
you attack and then you reverse the
victim and the defender and that's what
taylor lorenz is doing absolutely she's
denying she did the doxing she's
attacking people who who are calling her
out and she's making herself the victim
and the people who she attacked the the
you know the offenders
so it's funny because it's the left that
often tweets about that saying the right
does it but literally this is what they
do oh no i'm being it's like that
cartoon you receive the woman the
feminist and she's shoveling crap over a
wall and says opinions over the internet
and when they throw it back she goes
help i'm being oppressed it's like
welcome welcome to the real world listen
you do not
get to wield institutional power
as a weapon and then hide behind it
because now these people are starting to
realize what happens when other people
who also have the ability to wield
institutional power decide to strike
back and they're not going to like it
but i am done sitting around all we did
all we did is put up a simple message
taylor lorenz doc's libs of tiptop i did
not insult her i did not post her
address i didn't reveal any private
information about her i made a simple
statement yeah that's it yeah well part
of what makes this so hideous is the
fact that a few weeks ago before this
was even a story taylor lorenz was on
msnbc and she started crying because she
said she fears for what people will do
with each tiny little bit of information
about her that was leaked so she's
clearly very conscious about this kind
of thing and then she went on to publish
somebody else's personal private address
and then lie about it and then lie about
it all right well speaking of uh of
crying let's let's let's advance to uh
the next story in this saga which is
it's all it's all somewhat related but
this is it's a little bit different we
have this from politico
twitter's top lawyer reassures staff and
cries during meeting about musk takeover
vijaya gaday a key executive involved in
decisions to remove former president
donald trump and ban political
advertising expressed uncertainty about
the future of the platform i'll i'm not
going to gloat over someone crying
um i think it's a good example
nonetheless of the problems this company
has
elon musk did not do anything
the deal's not even done
all that's happened is they've they've
signed the document saying we're gonna
we're gonna have a deal
for all we know
doesn't go through for some reason
side note in the event the deal doesn't
go through twitter has to pay elon musk
one billion dollars okay if elon musk
screws up the deal he's gonna pay them
one billion dollars but i doubt that's
going to happen so
if the shareholders vote no on this deal
they have elon cornered these these this
company this is incredible let me just
break this down
elon makes the offer shortly before
their first quarter earnings report in
which the revenue is likely going to
show bad bad quarter so the stock will
go down elon musk offers them a premium
if they reject that and the stock goes
down now they're liable to the
shareholders for not accepting something
they they knew was it was a good deal
in the deal they agree to a one milli a
one billion dollar breakup clause if the
shareholders vote no elon musk gets a
free billion dollars so now the
shareholders are like if we don't vote
for this not only are we likely going to
see the stock plummet but we're going to
be out the company will be at a billion
dollars causing it to plummet even more
elon won then 4d chess if there's stock
plummets he just gets a bunch of robin
hood accounts buys it up anyway boom
elon wins he gets he gets all of their
toilet paper shares but so for those of
you may be familiar vajayagade is the
woman who was on the joe rogan
experience with me and jack dorsey and
she's breaking down and crying
many people pointed out
the reason she was on the show is she's
actually the person behind everything
that's been happening at twitter in
terms of all the wokeness the political
manipulation it's her
she's the one and now she's crying over
this
look i'm not here to gloat over the
crying you want to make fun of her for
crying and laugh about it fine i'll just
point out the crying shows
they've no they know they've lost this
is a major moment
oh reminds me of when the google
employees had the their big open house
or the
the big meeting after trump won and they
were all crying and and worried and it
the the tremendous angst that they
expressed about
their role in allowing trump to win and
defeat hillary clinton and
we saw them respond and react what i'm
wondering about is what's going to
happen
in the twitter world at the business
because there's going to be a resistance
there i think to what elon musk wants to
do the culture is so ingrained with the
wokeness there from the bottom and the
top and we saw with this with the
attorney crying here how do you say her
name again vijaya gaday
i can't try that one that's too hard for
me but um
it's an example of what he's going to
face with the personnel there and the
wokeness and he's going to face a
resistance like president trump faced
with the administrative state well the
first thing you use fire of agia and
then everyone else is well that's what
trump should have done with a lot of
people in the first place he should have
terminated some of these people and he
loves saying you're fired it's shocking
that he didn't but there's civil there's
civil protections on many of the
government employees right
on some of them but there were a lot of
them in the national security staff we
should have let a lot of people go right
away we had a lot of political
appointees that were allowed to hang on
elon elon musk can walk in and say
you're fired yes he owns it outright
it's remarkable seeing some of these
people they really don't understand
anything about work or companies because
some of these lefties are like elon musk
is you know i'm losing a bunch of
followers elon musk is causing a lot of
damage to the shareholders and it's just
like you realize he bought the company
100 there's no shareholders anymore it's
just him he's happy with it i hope
people understand that if you're crying
about the new boss that's coming in he's
going to fire you
if he finds that no yeah that's exactly
i was just thinking that it's remarkable
how dumb and
even really unemployable these people
are outside of any kind of environment
where they're being catered to by their
higher-ups the fact that somebody takes
over to the company that you're working
for and you immediately start publicly
trash-talking them is so ridiculous well
they've never had another job in their
lives well what their attitude should be
and i i grew up in the military and i
matured through learning how to be a
team player and a leader and work for
people and we have changes of command
and we have changes of administrations
that we had to respond to over the years
what your job is is to
find out where the boss wants to go help
him get there okay if there are problems
in his way identify what those problems
are and help mitigate those give them a
pathway you're supposed to be part of a
team and if you're not going to row the
oars in the direction that the new boss
wants to go you have an obligation to
resign
sheamus
this probably is their first job yeah
that's what i'm saying a lot of these
people probably got masters or something
got out of college at 24 and then apply
to twitter it's the first place they've
ever worked they probably view twitter
as a home yeah something like that well
and i've sort of joked about this in the
past but it's part of why we live in
such a bizarre world where conservative
people are afraid to voice their own
opinions and signal the fact that
they're on the right and left-wing
people are very comfortable doing so at
their jobs because when you state you're
a left-wing individual of this brand of
progressivism all you're doing is
advertising the fact that you're
unemployable
and yet it seems as if employers are
finding it like what are you gonna do if
you get rid of all the conservatives
fire everyone who shows up on time and
fire everyone who cares about doing the
job fire everyone who doesn't have an
entitlement complex i'm pretty sure
political protections political
discrimination only exists in washington
dc for the most part i mean maybe there
are some smaller jurisdictions but
dc protects political affiliation as a
protected class makes sense if you're
forced to go live in dc at least
partially because you're in congress or
whatever having someone say we don't
serve republicans is a huge problem
outside of there i'm pretty sure you if
you went to a company and said that you
were a leftist they could be like we're
not hiring you or if you were in the
middle of your job and said you were
leftist or a conservative they could be
like you're fired for that reason yeah
well it's an interesting point too
because you could have uh a particular
business that has to service a market so
for example if you were doing something
like producing conservative content you
probably wouldn't want to hire left-wing
people and it would be bizarre if there
was a law requiring you to do so
i don't think that hiring anybody that's
political makes sense if someone comes
in and they're like i identify
get out identity politics
well hold on there gender identity is
protected
that's that's it's pretty insane in my
opinion sometimes weird thing to bring a
job interview decide what your gender is
and then have that protected is insane i
understand immutable characteristics
that you didn't choose
but
if it's gender that you get to pick
that's weird and in new york gender
identity is described in law as
self-expression yeah which
self-expression is not that's that's
defies corporate logic we've we've
talked about this it's uh
there is no black and white approach to
upholding civil rights it's always a
gradient because everything is connected
to everything else there's this idea
that exists among many traditional or
classical liberals
where it's like if we enshrine in law
that men and women shall be treated
equally we're done we've done it we have
equal rights and then someone says okay
they're treated equally what does that
mean well it means you can't
discriminate against them based on you
know their biological sex it's like okay
well this bathroom says women only you
mean i'm not allowed to go in it because
i'm biologically male well that's
discriminating isn't it it literally is
in law in which case then you have
judges trying to say okay well there's
an exception an exemption in that one
like we we didn't mean that
you didn't what happens is a generation
goes by and people don't know what you
actually meant all that matters is
what's written down in law and you get
textualists who then just say and it
says you can't do it that's where we're
at now the 1964 civil rights act meant
some very obvious things
provide service to people don't kick
them out because of these
characteristics now it's
it's being challenged across the board
so what ends up happening is
you had that uh i think was a supreme
court case where they tried arguing that
i think this is what happened right
gender identity was considered the same
thing as sexuality in some court case
yes that's correct and
they're not but the court said so and so
i i think that's what brought us to
where we are now one thing led to
another because everything is
interconnected it's not a slippery slope
it's just dominoes falling over the next
thing that's going to happen is in new
york where they say
gender identity is just self-expression
well they have to do that because what
are they really protecting when they
protect gender identity if you are
biologically male and want to wear a
dress and call yourself susan that's
what they're protecting but what's the
difference between calling yourself
susan in a dress and calling yourself
volcipheron herald of the winter mists
while wearing a fursuit
literally nothing except for the
cultural interpretation but if a judge
can say one set of clothing is protected
and another isn't based on his personal
interpretation then you're going to
you're going to get a whole bunch of
challenges now judges are supposed to
interpret the law but the next step will
be in 20 years they're going to say the
law says my self-expression
that means i want to go to work as
volcipheron you think it's going to take
a whole 20 years for that no no no not
at all yeah
but um but actually i think it might be
reversing i mean look at what's going on
with twitter these people are crying
they've lost
this this mission that they've been on
well i'm not sure they've lost yet no i
mean i mean this this portion they're
losing there's good news okay and i
think we have good reason to be hopeful
for what twitter could become
and it was really quite bad okay
and
it wasn't doing that well as a business
was it
five billion dollars in revenues
it wasn't profitable
113 million active followers well they i
think they got up to 212 million at one
time yeah at one time but the latest
according to epoch times is 113 million
if that's true
their stock was about to plummet right
and so to ten bucks the people that work
for twitter should look at elon musk as
a savior because the business model was
not working the way these guys had been
running it
i just did some math at 7 500 plus
employees imagining that they're making
75 000 a year they're probably making
more than that it's more than half a
billion dollars a year in just an
employee salaries like that's way way
way too much for a company that's only
pulling in five billion i mean
i guess a fifth of your op a fifth of
your revenue is
is i don't know i haven't worked at
enough companies to know if that's
that just sounds like way too much uh
expenditure on employees and for a
company that can send its people remote
it doesn't make
i want to look at the business plan i
want to just say uh when we're talking
about jobs i think vijaya gada's job is
not long for this world
uh
sagar and jetty says
vijaya gaday the top censorship advocate
at twitter
who famously gaslet the world on joe
rogan's podcast and censored the hunter
biden laptop story is very upset about
the elon musk takeover elon musk
responded suspending the twitter account
of a major news organization for
publishing a truthful story was
obviously incredibly inappropriate
absolutely i can't imagine elon musk as
the owner of this company is going to go
in there and be like i'm going to keep
this person in fact he's probably going
to go in there and say you caused the
bulk of the problem so thank you for
your time and you are free to go
so derek i'm curious as someone who has
worked in the the white house and some
pretty high levels within government how
is social media viewed or discussed at
that level if at all
that's a good question it is discussed a
lot and
how to navigate it if you're in the
trump white house
the stories the media
and the way
big media mainstream media integrated
itself with the narratives of social
media and we see today that you know cnn
was actively coordinating with
you know people that were behind the
russia hoax to get the narrative right
and to expand on it
you know we worried about it a lot most
of us were looking at the social media
impact
as a as a national level of influence
for overseas because i dealt mostly in
the foreign policy world and what we
could learn from social media from
looking at social media accounts in
ukraine or the middle east or what isis
was posting so there's different ways of
looking at it from my perspective was as
an intelligence tool to get insights
into into groups organizations and
people
do you think this is part of why the
taliban was allowed to be on twitter
while trump was banned
well you look at and homey knee and
leaders of the codes force being on
twitter
and
the issues that they were taken and what
they were calling for violence against
israel violence against other people
calling out for the death of president
trump
and they were not shut down they were
not banned so the hypocrisy of the
leadership of twitter and when they talk
about values and threats of violence
they never followed up
their words with actions
in exercising their leadership in an
unbiased way they never did and that's
part of the reason they've had so many
problems and they lost so many followers
from 214 million to 113 active users
let's talk about something weird going
on weird weird goings on
we have this tweet from tyler carditis
tyler is the ceo of blaze media and he
says definitely something bizarre
happening with the twitter algorithm
impacting follower counts over the past
24 to 48 hours a few examples tucker
carlson is up 62 000 rogan 63 trump jr
jr87 and ted cruz is up 51 000
however by contrast rachel maddow is
down 18. anderson cooper is down 10. aoc
is down 27. kamala harris 22. hillary
clinton 17 what's going on
he goes into mention tulsi gabbard is up
rand paul is up ellen omar is down
here's my response
so tucker gained 62 000 followers in
half a day
he lost 50 followers yesterday this is
not people coming back news broke
yesterday something effed up is
happening now a lot of people responded
saying my account was inactive or i just
started a new account if you did not log
into your account and then you log in
that's not making a new account like
that's not making a new account you're
not all of a sudden now follow me for
the first time if you were already
following me just didn't use your
account it existed i had the follower
correct this is
new followers on his account tell me
this when the news broke yesterday
morning that elon musk had was set to
finish this deal with twitter why then
didn't people sign up maybe they said no
no i will only sign up once i hear the
news okay why didn't they sign up at 2
53 p.m when the news broke that elon had
secured the deal
why did they wait until the very next
day
to start signing up
tucker carlson lost 50 followers
yesterday
he gained 62 000 today
something does not make sense you guys
put it in my mind that there's some
nefarious stuff going on behind the
scenes where they're like oh better undo
that blacklist algorithm that we had
going in secret so that no one finds out
and now it's just this is the
recalibration i mean it's total
speculation i have no idea what's
happening right now well i think it's we
have to speculate and i think the issue
is
we're not gonna be able to understand
what's going on until there's someone
inside the elon musk's team gets in
there and asks the questions and
hopefully the records are preserved the
algorithms and what they're doing are
preserved and one can go back and look
at was there shadow banning how many
bots were there how many of
the the bots
how many bots were following you know uh
a congress lady or a senator yeah it's
real tempting as a social media network
to count the bots as people that are
logging in every day there's one point
how many did you say millions of people
log in a day 10 million 113 how many of
those are bots twitter's not going to go
out of its way to hunt them down and
eradicate them they're going to let
those numbers stand for so that they can
get a better investment
interesting i want to make uh i want to
highlight a few posts though there's a
possibility this is something
not nefarious it's interesting one
person said no people are just
reactivating their accounts because they
want to neener over the meltdowns good
point it may actually be that many
people deactivated their twitters
and have all reacted reactivated them
right now because you know they want to
be on twitter but hold on
someone else said
speaking for myself i am back for the
first time since 2018. my phone number
was banned from creating an account
until yesterday so somebody tweeted
saying that they were banned until
yesterday here's another one matt matt
ftm says i was finally just allowed to
tweet and use the platform two days ago
after being permabanned for four years i
assume i'm not the only one who was
sidelined for having too few followers
to make noise starting over fresh now
though and not going anywhere
several posts i've seen this i i
retweeted someone
a lot of people all of a sudden are
saying i was banned and now i'm a lot
back on the platform so yes
it seems like maybe there's a mix but
here's why i don't think it's just
conservatives coming back and
reactivating their accounts it means
simultaneously and by perfect perfect
physics
the left is deactivating as the right
reactivates i have seen evidence of that
uh i went on facebook for all my friends
from l.a who are actors out there and
man they are deleting their twitters
they are all up in arms about it i've
deleted my twitter yesterday i'm done
with twitter twitter so they're actually
deleting it they're not just saying
they're going to what happens if you
delete it from your iphone
well if you delete the app you still
have the account if you delete your
account that's a different story that
probably removes the follower number
i'm wondering how many are actually
removing their account they might not
want to be active but they want to sort
of follow and sean king he deleted his
account but then reinstantiated it
deactivated it and then reactivated it
later all the media reported he
deactivated he was off the platform and
then he came back like no i didn't i
didn't do that what he did so
so maybe maybe it really is that simple
that the people on the left are like
harambe saying they're leaving but elon
musk didn't do anything but they doesn't
even own the platform yet they say
they're going to canada but they never
go to canada yeah right they'll be back
i'll be back if we could find out how
many of these followers like rachel
maddow hillary clinton it was the same
person following all those five accounts
and they that one person left so it
looks like five followers were lost well
that's why it's not relevant um
i'm not adding up all the numbers yeah
i'm doing them individually like tucker
gained 62 000.
you think 62 000. so look i don't buy it
you mean to tell me that yesterday
when the news broke that elon did this
50 people were like i'm quitting and
deactivating my account
i wonder if he was shadow banned and
those people have been trying to follow
but it never was reflected in the
numbers here's one possibility people on
the left follow tucker carlson
and so
3 000 leftists quit and 2 950 or uh
conservatives join so it's a negative 50
number maybe
i don't think the left follows took a
carlson because we know this from
vijayagade leftists don't follow
conservative journalists conservatives
do follow left-wing journalists so it
seems
unlikely i look at this
yesterday conservatives were
deactivating their accounts they don't
buy it you know i think
people are mentioning they were unbanned
for the first time i think elon musk is
going to walk in the doors
and there's going to be something within
the system of twitter that is so obvious
and overtly political bias they got rid
of it they said get rid of it the new
guy's coming in and if he sees that
we're in trouble
and imagine what the press is going to
be preserve the evidence
well they got they have until october to
finish the deal yeah i know and it's
going to be very hard so i'm definitely
very interested to see what it is at the
very least this is exposed what we are
already knew and we already said and
which has been exposed a million times
before but basically these people
are weak and they're cowardly
you know
twitter was actively censoring
conservatives
and conservatives were still staying
it's not even as if elon has come and
said we're going to instantiate a policy
of censoring left-wing people they've
just said they're going to stop
censoring conservatives and they're like
i can't be here for that
that's the amazing thing people pointed
out that elon musk is not saying he's
going to wield power against democrats
he's simply saying twitter will stop
putting the boot on conservatives and so
they're all freaking out but liberals
like you said
do not want to read or listen to
alternative points of view even if
they're evidence-based
conservatives
tend to look at a wider cross-section of
information they get blamed all the time
for oh you only get your news from from
fox news that's the farthest thing from
the case because most everyone i know
and i think you know too
and the evidence bears it out even by
twitter's own own people
conservatives tend to look at other
sources of information that are not
confirmation bias-based yeah i mean
there have been studies about this that
we've talked about before on the show
that conservatives are more likely to
understand left-wing positions than
left-wingers are to understand
conservative positions but i think it
even goes deeper than that as
a very wise left-wing
liberal arts major told me when i was in
college when you're used to a position
of privilege equality feels like
oppression well that's what's happening
to them on twitter they're finally
getting a taste of some small iota of
potential equality somewhere down the
line and they are losing their minds
so i'm just trying to we got we got
we've got breaking news
coming in but um
madam
we got we got a ton we got we got too
much going on that was brilliant tell me
about it oh thank you thank you
yeah so sorry
i was i was checking uh important
saying a bunch of awesome stuff
thank you oh my gosh this is my best
episode
let's just keep let's stay on this topic
all right continue well no i mean i'm
all i was hoping you wouldn't call them
out like that like i'm out of insights
that's it for the night one of the
things one of the things that we're
saying is about um conservativism
looking outside the box kind of taking
in about i think that the scientific
method is actually a very conservative
function um and it's kind of the basis
of modern science there's other types of
science that aren't the scientific
method i don't even know if i come up
with one on top of my head but to say
like it feels like it should be this way
so let's just assume it's going to be
like that that seems like what you would
say is the liberal mind right now
unfortunately um being a little extreme
taking risks unnecessary risks
violates the entire scientific method
where you just try and disprove yourself
and have humility well it just reminds
me of something secretary rumsfeld said
about the known knowns the known
unknowns and then the unknown unknowns
okay and conservatives tend to be
in my view more
exploratory i think uh
liberals are driven by emotion well and
we've talked about this you use this
phrase a lot the left sees that or
believes that there is no truth but
power and so it doesn't matter what the
actual scientific consensus is on
something it doesn't matter what the
evidence says or what makes sense what
matters is what will get me more power
what will give me away
and if something comes up like in
climate science that challenges their
dogma
they attack it they don't want to
understand it they don't look at the
evidence and try to parse it out they
want to attack it deny it and go after
the person and discredit them
yeah exactly and even there whenever
they have a statistic that sounds like
it would support their case they
completely distort it so when they say
things like 97 percent of climate
scientists agree that humans are
responsible in some way for climate
change what they're leaving out is 97 of
climate scientists did not say we need a
green new deal or that the world is
going to end in 10 years or that it's
catastrophic but that's all assumed when
they say 97 of climate scientists agree
with our narrative but it's not the case
so twitter banned ads that go against
their narrative on climate change
that's overtly political the ads
themselves aren't gruesome or offensive
or objectionable they're just
politically objectionable if you have
the wrong opinion this company was
overtly biased
the left just lies and pronounces not
and they manipulate people and it works
so when i talk to people like stephen
marsh for instance who he was a good
dude came on the show he's like oh i'm
you know i'm just looking at things from
above i'm not on either side but his
world view is influenced by manipulation
and deception coming from the left and
he doesn't even know about things like
joe and hunter biden sharing a bank
account it's like well you're not in the
middle dude you're on the left you're
not doing the research and he's like i
did the research i'm like yeah i get it
you're doing research on like polls and
studies but you didn't know that that
joe biden hunter biden shared a bank
account now when i say that they call me
right wing for saying it when it's a
fact not an opinion
but uh let's jump over to this we got
breaking news so i was actually this is
why i got distracted because i had i got
a notification on my phone we have this
from the hodge twins it's actually a
veritas video breaking leaked audio of
twitter all hands reveals employees
press leadership
over what free speech means a plan for
mass exodus due to elon musk's
questionable ethics and questioning if
president trump will return to the
platform
shout out to james o'keefe and project
veritas elon musk you need to reinstate
them immediately as soon as you gain
control of the company let's play this
uh this video and see what's going on mr
musk plan on dealing with a mass exodus
considering acquisition
is the question of attrition um you know
as perak stated you know one of the
themes of today is continuity and
ensuring that prague and this leadership
team continues to operate the business
successfully on behalf of our users on
behalf of our customers and that has
obviously been a big topic of discussion
at the board and as i mentioned in an
area that is important to elon musk as
well because of the importance of
twitter as a service with no board in
place who will keep elon accountable and
how elon made it clear in public that a
large part of the reason he bought the
platform was because of our moderation
policies and disagreements in how we
deal with health this puts twitter
service and trust and safety as well as
anybody who cares about help on the
platform in a very difficult position
twitter service the role of our policies
and the capabilities we've built around
content moderation are fundamental to
keeping twitter safe
and growing i believe
that there is a lot of work we have to
do to continue making that better i want
to pause real quick in the middle that
we got another minute but i want to
point out conservatives are willing to
stay on the platform when they're
getting censored and the left is getting
away with it the left is unwilling to
stay on the platform if conservatives
aren't getting censored so twitter saw
the formula you can ban a conservative
and most conservatives stay you ban a
liberal they freak out and revolt only
ban the conservatives this is evidenced
by the fact that by sheer fear that elon
might bring trump back they're leaving
the platform
i say it this way
when you had the weak parent in charge
of twitter and the little kid was
screaming i want an ice cream cone or a
hold my breath
twitter's parag agrawal and vijayagaday
were like okay okay just stop screaming
and i'll give you the ice cream elon
musk is the dad being like
okay go hold your breath outside and
i'll have the ice cream inside you know
you're not getting ice cream but let's
uh let's play and now they're going i'm
running away from home and he's like
goodbye yeah here we go sometimes
that means more thoughtful moderation
sometimes that means making things
simpler sometimes that means changing
product incentives to be able to solve
problems through products sometimes
instead of policies during the last all
hands you said that you trust elon musk
the correct quote was we trust him so
who is we and talking to elon what made
you trust him and waved in the
conversation i had with him
when we were excited to have him join
our board that was because as a major
shareholder an opinionated user
we wanted
that voice in our boardroom so that we
could learn is there an updated
understanding on what free speech means
the question behind the question here
which is where might twitter's product
go as a private company in the future
once this deal closes to best gain
perspective on this as i said earlier
we'll find ways to bring elon for a q a
with all of you to understand better
what his vision for the future of
twitter might look like
i wouldn't say anything outright or
overtly crazy other than these people
are blind completely clueless
and they're right elon joining the board
was an opinionated outside perspective
that would help them but they they
blocked him so him coming in and just
saying i'm taking it over good shake it
up a little bit they have ideological
blinders
they
talk about moderation policies
they don't have moderation policies they
have extremist policies that are driven
by censorship of views that they don't
like they talk about safety but almost
all their their rules on safety dealing
with the covet outbreak turned out the
science wasn't on their side over time
drugs that they
said didn't work actually worked the cdc
was wrong on mass the cdc was wrong on
the the effects of the uh immunizations
on people
we have to be a little specific though i
i think the issue is that twitter
decided
one doctor was better than another
doctor when they shouldn't they
shouldn't be doing that youtube takes a
similar position in that they've
youtube's decided the same doctors that
twitter sided with are the correct
doctors and this is the problem youtube
you are not correct however i will say
on the mask thing
in what context
were you referring to the cdc mass
things
mass they were first saying mass
aren't needed right
and then they don't work and then they
said they're needed and then we found
out that the mass were not effective
against the size of the the virus but
but it is
and then it evolved up and down over
time okay so it was it was just strange
and it lost a lot of confidence of
people in the cdc on on that issue i
think the most important point is that
early on
twitter was on the side of don't discuss
lab leak theory
and they were also on the side of when
dr fauci came out in march of 2020
saying don't wear masks twitter was on
his side and he was wrong about that he
came back out later and says okay maybe
you should wear masks and twitter just
flips with him i'm like you cannot build
confidence with people if you can't give
them a cohesive set of instructions on
what the plan is they would just come
out and say oh well the science changed
okay well i think the i don't know where
we're at with the pandemic you youtube
has goofy rules i think uh it's fair to
say in addressing those goofy rules
masks stop you from spitting on people
so they have a certain a certain degree
of effect uh effectiveness okay so so
the sanitation issue it turns out that
getting it from touching something okay
you have a one in ten thousand chance of
it being transmissible okay if you touch
a contaminated surface
but we're first told that
if you touch a surface
you have a high chance of getting it and
everyone was cleansing everything people
were cleaning the canned goods coming
back from the grocery store based upon
cdc guidance
it turned out that was wrong it created
hysteria subway cars were being
sanitized every day multiple times but
it wasn't necessary yeah this is uh from
this conversation the obsession with
health and the obsession with safety is
really disturbing it sounds like
rhetoric and maybe this isn't the
conversation to have the ethical
conversation but compared to the board
meetings we would have at minds and the
conversations this is complete insane
rhetoric where you're like yo if you're
gonna spin this word around the house
like this you better let's talk about
what it means amen let's come back to
one point she said on there free speech
what does free speech mean free speech
means free speech except yelling fire in
a movie theater right you're allowed to
do that you're allowed to do that you're
allowed to yell fire in a movie theater
if it's empty no
no you're allowed but you can be
punished no you can't oh so this was
actually reversed i think in like 1968
so it's brandenburg v ohio i think okay
the the initial ruling in the early
1900s was that well you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater and the supreme
court overruled that saying yeah you can
you actually can do that can you go into
a restaurant be like there's rats all
over the place and then everyone runs
out of the restaurant and doesn't come
back that's not a a criminal issue
that's a civil tort issue for you lying
same with fire
uh
you'd probably yeah you'd probably get
sued by the business but it's not a
matter of uh law but that's not a matter
of criminal law but let's go back she's
she's ahead a leader at
the organization i i assume and she's
saying well what is free speech
well this was her uh she was really a
question from from employees yeah also
so the woman was getting questions and
she was asking the ceo it's indicative
that they still don't know what it is if
they're still asking the question also i
believe when uh oliver wendell holmes
said you can't shout fire in a crowded
theater he was using that as a
justification for censoring people who
were protesting the first world war
yeah
yeah that got overturned i think 1968
yeah so they'd go into a theater and
yell just to get people right no no so
they were not actual he was using it as
an analogy
they were passing out flyers
that protested the first world war and
they ruled that you shouldn't be able to
do that and his justification is well
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
so you can't do this either some people
are pointing out that um perrag agrawal
is was not born in the united states and
so the ceo who is dictating our speech
is that's very problematic that someone
who isn't you know from this country uh
my response to that is elon musk was
also not born in this country and would
also be dictating speech in this country
so um yeah either way you've got that
problem
so is it an issue i suppose the issue is
are our values being upheld and twitter
you don't i think twitter is
it is um
you guys ever play the game life genesis
on on oh windows 95 negative you
remember that one
so uh
it's a bunch of little dots little
squares pixels that interact with each
other in unique ways and it creates
predictable it creates patterns based on
certain rules
and in the version i had you had two
colors
basically
if you have 100 blue pixels and you drop
one red into it the red gets engulfed
instantly it just becomes blue that's
what twitter is twitter is 98.7 democrat
uh voting democrat donating anybody who
goes in there and is conservative is
crushed instantly their ideas don't make
it anywhere you're not going to be
sitting in a twitter meeting and they
say how do we deal with this this this
problem of harassment and be the lone
conservative being like
uh it's not harassment what are you
talking about you're gonna keep your
mouth shut because you're one out of you
know 30 people and you know they'll
harass you they'll take your job from
you so you do nothing all of the
policies then start moving further and
further to the left and going insane and
so the people at twitter genuinely do
not understand how insane they've driven
themselves as i've often described it
jack dorsey built a big toilet and then
stuck his mouth on the end of it and
started eating the refuse he created i
know it's a crass way to describe it but
this is what happened
people went on twitter started saying
insane things to get traffic the more
insane they got the more jack himself
was surrounded by the insanity that he
had welcomed
so what happens then is i'm sitting down
with jack and vijaya and joe rogan and i
said yeah your rules are overtly biased
your rules aren't right and jack says no
they're not and i was like you have a
misgendering policy you can't see that
that is a outright biased rule that
conservatives are are confused by and he
was like but we're trying to help people
who might be suicidal and i'm like
you're not helping body dysmorphic
people you're not helping transracial
people no you live in a bubble you live
in a bubble you can't see out of so
you've enacted policies that are insane
to the average person
and that's for a miniscule percentage of
the population you're changing all the
norms for a
minority of a minority of the population
but we're talking specifically i would
say the minority is the leftists
it's it's it's not even blair white is
is a trans person blair white doesn't
agree with with what these people are
saying it's not even an issue of in my
opinion trans issues it's an issue of
ideology
so what happens is you have white
progressive liberals who claim everyone
else is racist they claim candace owens
is a white supremacist they claim larry
elder is though is the black face of
white supremacy
it is their fringe ideology that is
dominating and getting these rules made
it's not even an issue of
are black people upset over racism yes
many are but they're not the ones
enacting these changes they're not the
ones going into twitter and demanding
twitter do these things for them some
activists are some aren't it is this
weird fringe cult that is going in and
making rules for everybody else while
believing that they're the white saviors
and you also have the issue of the trans
agenda which is trying to groom
people that have dysphoria or issues or
might be migrating to being actually gay
and say you're not actually gay you are
trans and you need surgery and you need
to but again though that's why
progressive women doing that correct
it's not so so you know a lot of people
bring up the idea of like a trans agenda
or whatever and
i'll say okay in the context that
doesn't refer to an individual who is
transgender it refers to the cult
because when you see a video of a white
liberal woman who is a straight married
woman but she's talking about how she
wants to teach kids these things it's an
issue of the cult
white
weird progressive fringe politics i
believe social media has has wrapped
them into a bubble of incendi
where they push policies that regular
people think are insane
i want to make it it's possible i'm
being pedantic with myself here i want
to make a slight correction the 1919
court case we were referring to about
yelling fire in a private theater it
wasn't even the person protesting the
first world war i looked it up to double
check they were just protesting the
draft in the first world war so it's
even worse than that but i wanted to
point that out and sam i hear what
you're saying but i think it's fair to
call the trans agenda because even
though not every single person who's
considered to be transgender is on board
with it it seems to be how they're
unified and behaving as a political
force that's what i'm saying if you're
saying it's an agenda to encourage
transgender or gender ideology
sure
if you're saying it's a trans agenda as
if transgender people are the ones
behind it i would say i disagree with
that because there for one the
transgender community is very very small
and if you go on twitter and if you look
at these videos it is typically like
white liberal women
however there are many non-binary
individuals who are advocating for the
stuff too i'm not saying they're not i'm
just saying
i think it's important to call out the
ideology while recognizing we're friends
with blair white who's amazing and
doesn't agree with them we also have a
similar situation with white liberals
male and female
pushing the in
the immigration agenda
that is not the dominant theme or the
dominant industry for the hispanic
community in this country regardless of
their from south america cuba poor
puerto rico or any place else okay
it's being pushed by the white liberals
and i should mention this of the
hispanic people i have met who are legal
immigrants they are not a fan they are
not fans of illegal immigration so the
idea that like this is an issue that is
being pushed by you know hispanic voters
as a black is ridiculous you're right
very often it's just it's white liberals
who want to pat themselves on the back
virtue signaling or big businesses that
want cheap labor
well let's talk about what the next step
is because my friends if you thought
elon musk was going to save you i'm
sorry we may have won a battle
i tell you this moment is like the
battle for helms deep
and we made one last ride
and then up in the in the break of dawn
we saw elon musk the white wizard coming
to our rescue but the war is not over we
still have to get the one ring of
censorship to mount doom
and uh what's happening now is
the bite administration is calling for
section 230 reform obama has called for
more regulations on speech
you've got ed markey calling for
uh algorithmic justice he called it
lawmakers are calling for greater
oversight of social media according to
the white house biden has long argued
that tech platforms must be held
accountable when they lose in the
private sector where they've controlled
the narrative for so long they are
falling back to the public sector and
they're going to try to use government
as their cudgel to beat people down and
maintain that narrative so battle may be
won
but we must get the ring of censorship
to mount doom yeah so when biden says
they need to be held accountable for the
harms they cause do you think he might
be referring to the fact that they
suppressed a true story about his son
which in part contributed to him being
elected as president of the united
states well they're losing that power
elon musk publicly comes out and says
they should not have done that and joe
biden's like oh geez man how am i going
to win 24. come on man
come on man i can't win an election
without big tech censoring people and
shutting down conversations around what
my kid does ask time magazine i can't i
can't what am i going to do what's their
oversight that they want to create
it's nebulous
but they're like we can't allow
disinformation i don't think they'll win
well but they've already
i mean they've already started doing
this remember they were telling large
social media platforms that they had to
censor certain information surrounding
kova 19
and they did yeah and we saw that uh
wasn't like media companies getting uh
subsidy on like vaccine issues or
something like that
absolutely when when uh what did we see
the democratic party went to twitter i
think it was saying certain people
should be banned and it was we had tom
fitton just the other day who was
talking about that so right right right
there was some kind of expose they did
where the democrats were actually
sending messages like hey get rid of
these people the coordination between
the white house and the tech media
companies
has been
i think
eye-opening and it's scary and the
collaboration and and the coordination
between the two is what mccarthy should
investigate if they get the majority and
they're going to need subpoenas and
they're going to need preservation of
record requests and those should go out
now
and it's going to be very hard even if
you have an aggressive republican
leadership in the house of
representatives
to get after this because you're going
to face resistance delays stalling
tactics from the administration and the
white house the executive privilege
issues all of that and they'll try to
run out the clock but they have to go
after it you have to begin the fight and
just like was putting up your billboard
tim you have to fight you have to let
them know there's going to be a cost you
have to give an example to others
our base needs it okay people need the
example to stand up and fight and go to
meetings and participate in the
democracy and they need to see their
leaders standing up i don't think kevin
mccarthy's gonna gonna do anything
i don't disagree with him
just ran in his parade over here well
there's hope but there's also hope that
one could get a different leader
and that's what we need we need uh a
speaker trump
maybe
what are they gonna vote for i have the
greatest speaker i'd like to ask you
something so i'm really curious about
how new this relationship between the
white house and these large social media
companies is was there any inkling when
you were in the white house that things
like this had been occurring under the
obama administration prior to trump
taking power
absolutely right ben rhodes talked about
how foolish the major mainstream media
is and the tech leadership he had
that he could manipulate them and he
made fun of them in private it came out
and he was embarrassed by that
but the key issue
is that he was facilitating and
coordinating this
with daily
messaging for coordinating the white
house messages and the cnns and the
msnbc's but also the social media lapped
it up
so we had that beginning in the obama
administration i'd say previously
you also had but wasn't as coordinated
or
as effective as we saw with you know the
advent of social media really growing
during the obama years i mean it's
12 years ago 14 years ago now right
so
things have moved along quite quickly i
i think we've got real problems here and
i think you know
we're gonna have to begin the turn the
turn is possible
but it's going to take aggressive
oversight
it's probably going to take another
executive
leader like a trump or a desantis or
someone to come in and put some teeth in
doj and sec and the federal
communications administration to get
after this in a way that will level the
playing field
you got to change the culture in these
industries and
that comes with the green i think
drain the swamp yeah
yes but you look at what happens to
robbie starbuck do you hear about what
happened to him in tennessee no they
kicked him off the primary the
republican party did they said he wasn't
a real republican it's the dude is more
repub like one of the most republican
republicans there is that should be
challenged in court because i think it's
violating
a number of laws i mean constitutional
requirements here to drop someone off
running in in the primary can uh primary
race there in tennessee i read something
about it i don't remember exactly what
the story was but i it appeared that
it's an overreach by the republican
party there but it's the establishment
it's the establishment going after the
base of the party yep
if we're going to actually see any
changes in november if the problem's
going to win there has to be a wave of
populist american first type america
first type republicans who win but if
the republican party itself is rejecting
these candidates and trying to keep them
out then
why would i bother voting for a
republican well we have a lot of wins
you know we've seen that in michigan and
other places okay and it looks like it's
going to be good in georgia and it's
going to be good in north carolina and i
think we're not in too bad a place in
places like
um i i actually i think
maybe it would be fair for me to say
that until the republican party itself
the national level comes down on
tennessee with with an iron fist weeding
out the corruption and condemning the
actions in booting robbie starbuck off
we should advocate that everyone tells
the republican party to go screw
themselves i'm not going to vote i'm not
voting for republicans until they make
that move and restore robbie starbuck
because i don't want i'm not going to be
party to corruption if they want to play
stupid pathetic dirty games if the
republicans of west virginia of maryland
of at the national level will not come
out and condemn this i'll tell you this
if they condemn it i'm good well in
maryland in maryland right here where
we're at
the state republican party is trying to
pressure county
committees of the republican party to
not support dan cox in the governor's
race
okay that's governor hogan okay trying
to stack the deck in favor of his chosen
successor against a real consent
conservative who's been endorsed by
president trump
so so uh
well elaborate on this tell us more
about what you know what's going on well
what they're trying to do is
influence every county
every county in maryland has a
committee
of republican leaders and they are
elected and if there's a
replacement needed they're appointed and
it's approved by the governor they're
trying and they're very important in
county politics and they're pressuring
them
to not provide any support
that means organizing
help for the campaign at the grassroots
level and disincentivizing people from
doing that
as individuals too
and that could stack the deck now i
think the reaction is going to be in
places like garrett and allegheny county
and washington county and others that
are basically conservative in trump
territory it's going to it's going to
not it's not going to work at all okay
you say that they're pressuring them
what is an example of that kind of
pressure
withholding support
denying them access
they're not going to get the benefits of
being part of the the larger state
operation is that not blackmail
call it what you will there it's
politics it is politics the
establishment be it republican or
democrat are happy
to see the republicans fail and lose if
it means populists people like trump and
people who like trump don't win
so
what's the solution
i don't know
that i i genuinely think you know do i
think that lindsey graham cares at all
no he high fived he fist bumped kamala
harris he does not care he is a crony
establishment chill we did it lindsay
yeah so is kevin mccarthy so was mitch
mcconnell they're all terrible the
republican party is despised by so many
people in this country and it's sad
because there there are good there are
more good republicans than uh than good
democrats but the republican party is
just run by by pure corruption the
democrats are too don't get me wrong the
chamber of commerce republican elite
okay and i i call it the uniparty elite
because there's not that much difference
george wallace once said there's not a
dime worth a difference between the
leadership of the republican and
democratic party that was back in 1968
or 72 something like that that's ancient
history for most people but that's what
was said and it's more true today
than back then okay the uniparty elite
has sold out to china
the chamber of commerce supports both of
them
leadership in banks and veteran capital
capital they give big money
to
victory funds for republicans at the
senior level they give the same kind of
money to the democrats
because
it's all about the green for them and
you know feathering their nest
yeah there's a i quote it i quote this
every now and again on the show but it's
called woods's law from tom woods
whoever you vote for you end up getting
john mccain uh and it's true that in
terms of the actual party platforms yes
the parties are different i certainly
don't agree that they're identical but i
completely agree with you that at the
level of leadership they're pretty much
all in bed together let's i i do want to
at least talk about a reason why you
should vote against democrats not that i
think it's perfect to vote for
republicans but we have this story from
timcast.com amazon leadership held a
session to discuss matt walsh's
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus being problematic a customer said
that it's teaching kids to kill and
bully transgender people what this is
matt walsh's book
this is amazon
being insane and going over the top now
i there's not much to say beyond this we
know amazon does this we know who they
are that's the news my point is the
reason why i would like to vote for a
republican is to get rid of this stuff i
want school boards to say look we don't
want critical practice in our schools
what does the left say
republicans are banning math
and this works because there are people
who just watch cnn
they believe it and then i'll respond
and say nobody banned math well what
about rhonda says his betting math books
he banned math books that were filled
with critical practice
i don't want books banned i want
curriculum of critical praxis and
christian praxis band because kids
should be taught two plus two equals
four moving on if the kid says i have a
question about mommies and daddies talk
to your parents about it if the kid says
i have a question about my spirituality
and my faith back talk to your parents
about it keep it out of the schools
practice i the implementation of the
ideology should be kept out if those are
the rules we're playing by i'm totally
fine with it
amen man
good story what we need is
more candidates to step up and run for
election
that believe in the things that you
believed him that believe that crt
in the classroom is wrong we need more
people running like the parents in
loudoun county who challenge the school
board we need people to stand up and we
need people to show up to vote and
that's how you take the party back and
that's how you bring real change it
doesn't happen overnight it didn't
happen overnight for ronald reagan who
first made the speech in
1964 in support of barry goldwater it
took 20 years so it's it's uh i have no
issue
if a school has a book on critical race
theory in the school
i have no problem if the school has a
bible in the school i have no problem
the teachers say look i don't care we
don't want to ban those books you can
read it you can ask questions about it
my issue is with what's called praxis in
this instance it's not critical race
theory it's critical race applied
principles or critical race praxis the
left calls it critical race praxis
which is the implementation of the
ideology in other subjects
an example would be
writing a math problem that says
sheamus is a white male who is stopped
by police and frisked seven times per
year andre is a black man who has
stopped 247 times per year what
percentage of stops are so it's supposed
to be a math problem but they inject
critical race theory into it and that's
the praxis now we call it critical race
applied principles because that spells
crap and we don't want crap in our
schools
um but no in all seriousness the left
doesn't call it critical race practice
which is already crp which is crap
basically well race has an ra in it so
you could just call it crap as well
it's just funny how
pedantic we have to get about
distinguishing between these different
forms of left-wing thought which are
near identical as conservatives when
they just say everyone who disagrees
with them is a nazi and that's the one
label that they use
well the problem i think is
they lie all the time yeah and it works
yeah look at the story they then lie
about uh taylor loretta is a great
example she went on cnn and said the
right-wing media lies
and it's fascinating because
that's projection that's always
protection
right deny you know attack reverse
victim and offender it's them who's
lying you can only trust me it's people
like brian stelter who tells you not to
watch fox news
because he's guilty of that too
explaining that it's her job to tell you
what to think well that's our job and
then they denied it later and then
snopes comes out and says that's not
true it never happened or or joe biden
reaching out to shake the hand of
somebody that's not there and then and
snopes comes out and says he never did
it or what was it what was it snopes i
think it was snopes he never actually
did it and it's like dude
you're fact-checking an opinion with
your own opinion yeah you're just lying
that's that's what they do it's the game
they play and then they come up with
something like the 1619 project the new
york times and they infuse our schools
with it which is an ideologically driven
fabrication of american history
especially the founding the founding
fathers the declaration of independence
the constitution was opposed to slavery
only two states and only two that's
right in the declaration the
declaration really did mean all men are
created equal two states opposed it
georgia and south carolina
you had to compromise at that time the
letters the history really tells you
that it really wasn't based upon
slavery or racism that there was really
a movement to move beyond that and
oppose slavery one of the original uh
grievances in the declaration of
independence was that the king had taken
people from their homeland brought them
there against their will and was using
them to wage war against them they
jefferson took that out because the
southern states that were pro-slavery
would not sign on so long as
the other colonists uh and leaders
opposed slavery now
they had slaves and it was bad
a lot of bad things happened many
countries still have slaves it's it's
really really bad
but
that that i think i don't know if that
was the uh the biggest mistake made or
but it was a big mistake because that
divide
that compromise
it didn't end there
that that tacit agreement of look we'll
overlook this for now so we can win a
revolution and then 80 years later we're
in civil war
and now you know and then eight years
after that well world war ii but we'll
that's not domestic you ended up with
jim crow laws you ended up with the clan
you ended up with this conflict that was
just
seemingly never ending and if you look
back at everything we're dealing with
today it's all rooted going all the way
back to even before this the problem is
they need you to believe that the
founding fathers were evil so that they
can justify destroying american culture
because from the ashes of the old they
will build a new correct they want a
completely different system what they
want is a multicultural democracy people
need to understand when elizabeth warren
comes out and says this is dangerous for
our democracy and these democrats say
this they are not referring to your
country because you
good sir watching the show believe in a
constitutional republic not a democracy
and conservatives say you're wrong we're
not a democracy we're a constitutional
republic
no you don't you misunderstand they are
telling you
that there is a new multicultural
democracy growing in the united states
they're not making mistakes about it and
they're going after the symbolism they
want to invalidate the fourth of july
they want to deny its value and they
want to move to a june 19th type of
celebration that will overshadow
the july 4th celebration i do think it's
odd that we celebrate the introductions
to war so often like pearl harbor july
4th what other days got us into war that
we celebrate i don't know but then 9 11
9 11 was another one but not celebrating
we don't well you could say we observe
we observe and or celebrate the fourth
of july is definitely a celebration why
don't we celebrate the day that the war
ended well good point but july february
right july veterans day is the only
example i could find and they changed
the name from armistice day celebrating
the end of the war to veterans day
celebrating the warriors themselves but
by the way we were at war for a year
before the declaration of independence
technically way longer than that
so uh
the the american war for independence
took 20 years
and a lot of these these moments i mean
they were going back 10 or so 20 years
before i think 10 or so years before the
signing of the declaration so the the
british regulars shooting people the
conflict the confiscations all that was
going on it just wasn't at the point of
people marching towards each other
i think that they celebrate the
inductions into war because it's war
propaganda they use it like remember
that we're the victim and we had to
fight i don't know that's how i that's
how i've been phrasing it so maybe i
don't know what's up with the june the
june 19th thing that you were talking
about what is that exactly that was the
day
that union soldiers made it to the uh
last place in the country in texas i
think it was gal was it galveston yeah
where uh the last slaves had not been
informed they were free men and finally
ended slavery okay so it's worth
celebrating as an end of slavery kind of
thing i don't think it has anything to
do with july 4th though i don't know why
those two would be in the same
conversation i i think june teeth is
cool i think i think like you know we
get a holiday in june to have barbecue
and celebrate freedom and independence
i'm totally for it slavery was abhorrent
and it took that long to get rid of it i
say we do another holiday and we
celebrate the end of slavery the real
end of slavery and we also have the
fourth of july when our founding fathers
set forth a new nation that was one of
the first at the time to challenge these
these monarchs these absolute
authorities and say of for and by the
people was it perfect no but it planted
these seeds and of the seeds planted we
were uh blessed with people like
frederick douglass
who challenged the american people to
uphold the words that they themselves
had put in their own constitution about
all men being created equal which
ultimately led to the abolition of
slavery and many other countries
retained slavery and still have slavery
to this day slavery was bad the fourth
of july declaration of independence the
constitution are all good things
juneteenth is also also a good thing i
will take two holidays absolutely
but also for whatever reason we are a
nation which doesn't want to celebrate
the fact that we ended slavery we want
to scold ourselves for the fact that it
ever happened even though virtually
every culture throughout all of history
has had some form of it and we ended it
well it's a political cudgel but
the democrats wield it all the time but
if you go back and you know
louis gohmert did a good monologue on
that on the house floor
about the history of the democratic
party and slavery
they were the south the south in the
civil war
they were jim crow they were the kkk
they were the anti-sega they
reinstituted segregation under wood
woodrow wilson okay
segregated the government and the army
again
so
you know the democratic party
acts as though they are the defenders of
freedom and and of the slaves but they
were the ones behind it for
most of the american history and they're
also the party that just tried to repeal
the civil rights provisions from the
california constitution only a couple
years ago yeah it's funny i was thinking
about this the other day they also argue
that there was a party switch and so the
democratic party can't be held
accountable or looked upon negatively
for the fact that they supported slavery
they supported jim crow etc
and yet
when you look at the nation as a whole
everyone is to blame right basically all
white americans are to blame to some
extent for slavery even though it ended
the the history of it still remains but
then when you talk about the democratic
party oh well the legacy of that just
disappeared instantly right the party
switched and then the legacy of slavery
and racism within the democratic party
just vanished overnight and not not in
the country as a whole just in like the
pocket where it's convenient for us to
say disappear even though studies show
that white liberals dumb their language
down when they talk to black people
every it was it was actually this one
moment
where every single democrat like a
strike of lightning exactly just went i
was wrong
and the whole country changed it's true
yeah and every republican was hit
at once conversely by that same
lightnings
[Laughter]
oh no
they've sent the racism to us no they
wouldn't say oh no they'll go oh
yes
well let's let's talk about what's going
on here in washington county so for
those that aren't familiar
um we are in western maryland and uh
we're uh i live in west virginia
officially but we work out of western
maryland
and i i don't think we'll be doing that
much longer because i think that the
policies of the state are insane and
what you often see is
leftists not understanding how taxes
work
not understanding how businesses work we
just actually is a really great tweet
david hogg
you know the guy from parkland
yes you see this tweet he said no i
tweeted it it's very funny it's too
difficult to form an llc this is
ridiculous there's too many regulations
and people were like accidental
conservative moment no it's a young kid
who did not realize how difficult it is
often now when you get older you get
experience it's actually relatively easy
but uh i'll tell you the challenges
the first formation of a company i did
was confusing and very difficult because
we didn't imagine someone walks up to
you and they hand you five bowling pins
and say juggle you'll be like okay okay
i can't do that and like figure it out
take you a long time to figure it out
once you get the hang of it you can mix
it up and you're juggling i know how to
do this yeah where i'm at now with this
company it's really easy to start
companies and and work with it but i
have a team we have accountants we have
lawyers for a regular person it's so
difficult and so what we end up seeing
with many other people on the left is
they don't start companies so they have
no idea what's going on no they go to
government and then the government
passes laws like how do we increase tax
revenue i know increase taxes well i'll
tell you what the result of that is
we're leaving yeah we're moving our
headquarters over we've been building
freedom stand for a few months we
already have many employees who are
already
reporting out of there and we're going
to move everything to west virginia
because we're 10 minutes away because
it's almost heaven yeah yes yeah is that
is that the slogan or something john
denver
okay but no i think it's funny every
time someone on the left tries to do
something even remotely productive they
end up dropping some kind of
conservative take about it he's like
yeah man it's really hard to start this
company he's like oh my god i actually
did something in the real world
now he has a conservative opinion how
interesting this is interesting um jen
perlman who we've had on the show
who is a progressive democrat
was tweeting about billionaires paying
their fair share
and i said how much do you think is fair
is 55 a fair share and jen responded
that
perhaps
25 to 30 percent if you get rid of the
loopholes was a fair share and so i said
are you saying you would want to reduce
the tax burden on billionaires if you
could close the loopholes and they said
yeah i think so and i'm like
i don't know if i agree with that
completely but that's an interesting
take i i also wonder if they really
understand what loopholes mean
i don't think they do no cause i don't
think they would be arguing for that if
they understood what the tech loop tax
loophole really was well a lot of the
tax loopholes what they call loopholes
are
built in to incentivize businesses
investors entrepreneurs to do things
that the government wants them to do to
get them involved in economic zones in
underprivileged areas
low-income areas
it's about trying to bring in
high-tech businesses and give them a tax
break
in an area like washington county so you
get high-tech companies coming in
instead of
low-paying
warehouse jobs why would they call that
a loophole and not a tax break incentive
because they don't actually want people
to be incentivized to do good things i
just want to punish anyone who's more
successful than that no it's because
look i think most of them never never
ran a business yep they don't pay
business taxes in their mind they were
told evil billionaires aren't paying
their fair share yes the problem i have
with that is i'm like look i'm with
steve with with bannon on this one tax
the rich however i don't think giving
the government like
the idea
in and of itself but
government's not gonna do a good job
with it so i don't know how i ultimately
feel with the end results of that but
the issue is
they don't actually have a definition of
what fair means yeah fair share rhymes
it's catchy it's a rhetoric it doesn't
mean anything that's why i said it's 55
percent fair you're not going to get a
straight fair welcome to earth dude
fairness come on but when you look at
say the income tax 50 of people
that earn income do not pay an income
tax right and the top one percent pay a
tremendo i don't know what the number is
but it's overwhelming amount so if you
actually break down the tax burden
um uh by bracket
most people receive more benefits from
taxes than they pay into it most people
even up to like 100 or 200k per year
it's only around or after that people
start actually paying taxes and it's the
overwhelmingly the one percent and the
billionaires who are paying the taxes
that fund the benefits for all of the
poor i like i like that i have no
problem with that that's i have a
problem with with the government being
unaccountable with being bloated and
corrupt the idea that
rich people are you know we pay a
percentage in taxes and that goes to
helping poor people have cleaner water
or roads i like it you know we're only
as strong as our weakest link but we
don't have that
we've got a broken tax system we've got
leftists who don't understand it who are
being manipulated then impose tax laws
which hurt their own states and we have
bloated government that siphons money
off for bs reasons we have like gender
package pakistani gender studies
corporations that are considered
multinational that bounce from country
to country depending on the tax levels
they have bank accounts in panama the
panama papers breaks and shows all these
people have like they're hoarding their
wealth offshores this is the real life
reality so how do you deal with that
corporations aren't going to sit around
and pay you exorbitant taxes they're
just going to move their money can i
give you an example i've been
campaigning and i've been going door to
door i'm trying to hit 200 to 250 homes
every day
talking to people that are paying taxes
older people in their homes younger
people just getting started with young
kids
and in washington county
we have a tremendous surplus the amount
might be 40 50 million dollars in excess
revenue
they're talking about a three million
dollar property tax cut for the whole
county that will amount to about fifty
dollars for an average family making
fifty thousand dollars a year living in
a moderate priced home of about 180
thousand dollars fifty dollars total
rebate
the assessments in in this county
we get reassessed one-third of the
houses get reassessed every year
the assessments are going up so it's
going to be almost 100 a month more for
that average house so we're giving 50
back but we're taking 1150
from them
that's driving elder people out of their
homes they're a part of the fabric of
the community we want the grandparents
and the elderly to be there because
they're part of that community they're
important but they're having to leave
for west virginia for pennsylvania or go
to florida so maryland is a ridiculous
state
and the taxes are so insane
west virginia is literally you know a
hand
we could drive a half an hour and we're
at our new uh headquarters
is that half an hour drive
is it worth losing
hundreds of thousands to millions of
dollars that well that's ridiculous
so maryland
it doesn't seem to understand that you
know i understand maybe for like a brick
and mortar business but the nature of
our business and the growth we're having
we have no choice but to leave the state
and that means maryland will end up
losing tax revenue instead of just
saying we will compete for your business
with west virginia you could have
something where like certain areas of
maryland have a tax certain tax rate but
the further west you go it starts to go
down so it becomes a little more like
the neighboring states they do the
opposite they they increase so uh the
way it works is if you're a resident of
west virginia and you work in maryland
they charge you an additional tax wow
instead of saying thank you for bringing
your business here they say we're going
to punish you for bringing your business
here yeah well and people don't really
understand that this is a matter of
incentives like you said that that's
what it is it's a punishment of course
know nothings look at that and go hey
they're raising money for our budget
i've discussed and broken down the
laffer curve on this show before a lot
of lefties
who don't know anything about economics
which is to say most lefties will
actually tell you the laffer curve
doesn't exist that's not true no
left-wing economist even says that the
disagreement is just over where the
parabola peaks conservative-leaning
economists tend to say it's somewhere
near 20 left-wing economists might say
as high as 70 percent if they're really
crazy but ultimately people are not
going to work for money when they can't
keep as much of it it's really basic
stuff
i just think it's
a tremendous oversight
for there to be a tri-state area between
virginia maryland west virginia and
maryland's like we're going to make it
more expensive so everyone's like why
would i be in maryland well it's similar
to illinois illinois is surrounded by
red states lower taxes higher productive
productivity more economic growth and
illinois is losing population the taxes
go up because the more people that leave
the more the producers leave the more
those left behind have to pay to support
the gargantuan government apparatus
that's in place grassroots atlas
shrugged well you know we see evidence
of this kind of thing in the real world
too so despite all of the lies the media
said to convince people otherwise after
the trump tax cuts we saw a revenue
increase our deficit increased as well
because increased spending outpaced the
increase in revenue but the left used
the fact that the deficit increased to
argue
that we lost revenue it actually wasn't
the case they were just lying about it
but when you tax people less they have
more incentive to work and they generate
more wealth for the economy and then
take a look it's not just your income
tax it's not just your property tax
it's the higher gasoline
tax it's the higher sales tax it's the
fees that they pass on on cable directv
the water costs more all these things
are passed on okay
more so here than in west virginia
well and they know this it's interesting
they know this because when it comes to
taxing cigarettes or alcohol or even
gasoline it's understood that there's an
agenda there and the agenda is we want
people to use less of this so they're
willing to recognize when it's
convenient for them that when you
increase taxes on something you end up
with a less productive market there
you're not able to sell as much of it
and yet when it comes to human labor
they're completely blind to it you know
what else is interesting this crypto
stuff uh they didn't start taxing it
until like 2018 i think uh and so
basically there's like another 700
billion dollars in the economy that
maybe isn't accounted for right now that
untaxed just wealth was just created out
of nothing so that's true considering uh
the mass printing of money
the explosion and the money supply i'm
not sure if 700 billion dollars has puts
a dent in it yeah right it's up to
2 trillion and crypto
there abouts you see fluctuates west
virginia's got constitutional carry
there you go
it's it's just
western maryland
i guess the way the states have
structured themselves they can't
adapt properly fast enough i don't know
it just seems ridiculous to me that the
current system is too sluggish to
realize
the western maryland system they're
going to be losing
prominent industry
why did they not make it so you could
pay taxes online when you were at the
white house i don't know if you were
involved with the economic stuff at all
but like to an act of congress like why
would they not focus on streamlining
that process so you can go and click a
few buttons have your payment go direct
from your bank account
instead they make you like file all this
paperwork and search for things and go
to this and then they can't and then
it's like i gotta pay them well that's
that's that's that's like 21st century
incompetence and sluggishness
this is lobbying there's big companies
that make billions of dollars off of tax
filing preparation well here here's a
question i have for you i i took two
months with facebook to try and get
validated to have a campaign page
it took me two months and they even used
snail mail in the process which slowed
the pro the whole thing down i sold my
house from the time i called the
internet company open door
until i got a check in the mail it took
me 13 days i never saw a person
yet facebook a modern company
two months to validate me as a person to
be able to run political ads
yep bureaucracy so
is it this is too big the american
government has too many people working
there um yes nothing ever gets smaller
no programs ever die nope
exactly that's a load now they got to
know that if if you hang on to a dying
system and you refuse to shut shred it
apart it's going to get overthrown like
that's the inevitable if you look at
history from but thousands and thousands
of years in the past that's what happens
with societies if you were refused to
reform but what happens is
as the culture starts to decay and break
down
many people recognize we need a reform
or it's going to fall apart and once
that happens people say
well i can't count on you so i better
grab as much silverware as possible as
this ship sinks and that's the thing
and then that's what's happening right
now we've gone through things like
reinventing government okay
that was a big thing i think in in the
clinton years we had george bush
reinvent and redesign the whole
intelligence community 16 agencies and
develop the defense i mean the
department of national intelligence it
didn't solve anything really it just
created another layer of bureaucracy
more jobs
more elite
but it's not any better did you guys
consider defaulting on the interest of
the federal reserve i wasn't involved in
that that would have been mr minchin and
you know others so but let's ask the
audience did you ever consider
defaulting on the debt to the federal
reserve just the interest the interest
just the interest
so uh get those super chats in we're
gonna read your comments smash the like
button if you haven't already head over
to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members only segment coming
up around 11 p.m sheamus by the way i
want to say it wasn't a super chat but i
glanced over at the right moment and
noticed that someone in chat said
interesting that the guy with the irish
flag behind him just commented on
alcohol taxes that's right that's right
all right let's read some super chats we
got andre who says something definitely
changed in twitter's algorithm all of a
sudden i'm getting hundreds of likes on
my comments many replies i'm pretty sure
i didn't become super witty overnight
you see what i'm saying it's not just
follower count
all of a sudden people are getting crazy
engagement yeah i have my tweet from
yesterday has more than double the likes
of any other tweet i've ever put out you
were un listen
ian do you think conservatives like you
i think everybody likes me no but i mean
like
obviously they they're critical of you
you know probably yeah people are
critical of me in general but does it
does it make sense that the people like
you you'll get a mixed reaction
sometimes you'll get once or twenties
yeah yeah does it make sense that all of
a sudden everyone just agreed with you
and liked your stuff no this is
completely um anomalous i i'm not i
don't know i mean it's a great tweet
don't get me wrong
when we win a battle i do not celebrate
i focus on how to win the next battle do
girls you're meeting in bars now like
you that's probably what my old
girlfriends are finally liking myself
all right all right girl ladies i'm back
all right we got raymond g stanley jr
says just because more fight back thank
you very much morick says do a vosh
versus alex jones debate on free speech
trans and culture war no uh no matter
the harm to my eardrums i will subscribe
uh uh a years to listen to that thank
you elon twitter is now a better place
well
vosh has the very uh calm and slow talk
well alex you need to understand that
you can't make that argument and alex
would be screaming you know
maybe but uh look as much as i can say
vosh is one of the few leftists who will
come on the show and people have a lot
to criticize them over especially with
the kids and the grooming stuff
uh
i'd like to have a different leftist
come on and debate somebody but they
don't want to do it uh
matt bender said he was going to email
us did he
i haven't seen that even cause i told
him to email me and you
he didn't do it no i haven't seen him we
invited him on the show that's funny i
invited him on the show last time and he
was like whatever happened to that and i
was like bro you can come on the show
like we'd love to have a left podcaster
uh b-i-n-d-r
and b-i-n-d-e-r
and he didn't
didn't get anything from him it's been
like a week or whatever so you know i'm
not surprised
all right let's uh let's grab some more
super chats
light giver says brussels has warned
musk that twitter must comply with your
opinion's new digital rules or face
fines or ban
yes i'm pretty sure elon musk is going
to adhere to these rules i don't think
elon musk is going to walk in and be
like okay everybody um anyone can post
anything right now just do it i kind of
disagree i think he's going to say
whatever's legal in the united states is
legal on twitter and
whatever's legal and whatever state
they're incorporating which is
california at the moment is now state
laws you got to adhere to state law
maybe they'll move the corporation to a
better state that has better local laws
ian let me ask you something what is the
challenge associated with that because
yesterday on the show you said it would
be difficult to create a policy and
you're mentioning the first amendment
now is there some reason the first
amendment will be more difficult to
implement than the policies they have
now i'm curious what the pitfalls are as
someone who's worked with the social
media company before one of the main
ones is that company countries like
brussels will just not host twitter them
like china it won't be like mines isn't
in china you know they won't host it
because it's a free speech policy um the
another downside with having uh one when
i call it authoritarian when it's a
corporation because they're just
inherently authoritarian by nature but
when you have one authoritarian at the
top whether it's elon musk or any any
corporate owner they can tell you it's
free speech but then completely just
block everything the next day they don't
have to like it here there's no laws you
know that's the problem with saying your
terms of service are free speech there's
no constitution that upholds that it's
the the will of the the corporate
overlord so you need to go outside of
terms of service to to really
instantiate i love that word third time
we said it tonight free speech it's got
to be enshrined in the code itself that
there is interesting some way to to take
control of the network on your own if
you're not happy with the way other
people are running it and build your own
but brussels is not for free speech then
they can they can do that on their own
in my opinion but i don't think that we
should we should allow countries that
are not for free speech to dictate how
we run ours
yeah i think what'll happen is elon's
gonna say okay in the united states we
have free speech in europe you don't
and then people will use vpns to get to
the website anyway or they'll move to
the united states to get out of their
totalitarian countries
vp anarchies people are going to start
downloading virtual shield yeah yeah how
many people are using a vpn to watch
this show tonight from china it's
updated well yeah maybe
jesus uh crisp tris crisp says tim cass
daily wire and the blaze are triumvirate
of truth oh yes i mean there's there's
other people involved in there isn't
there i love this person yeah what about
joe rogan
all right let's see catoth swiss says
but taylor needs those sweet sweet
victim points tim yeah i know it worked
out for her we got the hey tim pool's
fighting back and she got the oh help
i'm a victim everybody wins right that's
the culture war
i just i'm sick of the lies so
you know sending a message where it's
like you want to wield institutional
power that is the washington post i'll
wield institutional power that is a time
square billboard
shout out to the to the daily wire for
the assistance
all right
the senate says it's a picture of
palpatine hey tim you should buy another
billboard and talk about biden's crooked
dealings here's some cash to get you
started you can't
political ads are not allowed in most of
the times square billboards so you can't
do it maybe it's not a political ad
maybe it's just an advertisement for
meeting with the big guy oh yeah that is
an interesting challenge though
uh when when donald trump was looking
into what biden was doing they said it
was political but biden hadn't even
announced that he was running for office
he was retired at that point also yeah
what an insane standard but this is what
will happen if if you go and say look i
just want to talk about what joe biden
did look like it's political because
he's a politician yeah i'm like but i'm
not talking about anything policy-wise
i'm talking about criminal activity i
don't like that they call obama
president obama now that he's not
president anymore there's like this
weird um what does that have to do with
what i was talking about like you're
saying he's all once in politics always
in politics and you can't go after him
anymore like biden now that he was vice
president hello mr vice president when
he's out office like it's um some some
weird tradition that we refer to old
presidents as president bush or
president obama i don't know the
president i think the titles of the
individual is what matters what matters
is they will make up an excuse to block
you from trying to call they're asking
us if he's still political i just want
to say you know ian some people are
still calling biden vice president
including
what an absurd idea right if someone's a
political figure you can't investigate
them for a crime or that's political
unless of course it's donald trump or
marjorie taylor green and then it's fair
game all right we got this one from jl
who says my kidneys are shutting down
and i'm stuck in a hospital bed can
someone please take over the ian shaft
cam meme for me please
get healthy sir get healthy
all right g money says tim and ian check
your dms i just made a remix of the
beautiful chicken city acapella tim
posted
it's uh was it twitter5420 so i posted
an isolated vocal track we were
recording the chicken city theme song
earlier today dude i have some
incredible harmonies for that i'm super
so we were we were tracking the second
verse and so i put the camera up and i i
just recorded nothing but me singing and
put it up on instagram it was like a
joke and the harmonies are so good that
i wrote i think it could be a hit song
yes it's incredible yeah this song is
about chicken city and it's gonna be
epic so uh i played it on my instagram
on the acoustic and now we're finishing
out it's it's it's a beautiful beautiful
folk song beautiful
all right let's see we got
amanda dilts says today is my son
hunter's fifth birthday can you please
wish him a happy birthday he really
loves all the voices that sheamus does
oh that's that's
adorable what uh what voice should i do
ben shapiro okay first of all happy
birthday happy birthday to you embody
the archetypal how how old is he turning
five years old hunter embody the
archetypal five-year-old be a hero
hunter that's my brother's middle name
okay you got benjamin hero and jordan
peterson alex what else
jack dorsey happy birthday happy fifth
birthday you're bad trump was first of
all five was a very good year for me i
hope it's a good year for you too
frankly quite frankly it's what i you
probably won't make as much money as i
bet it's when i started doing best by
fortune got a job very early
is that it i don't know throw another
voice at me any voice any voices they
want for this kid's birthday
uh gilbert gottfried
oh man can i do it happy fifth birthday
thank you thank you thank you that's
great thank you recipe thank you yes
the great gilbert
all right grant gordon says tim you guys
got to go and see and review the new
movie out of the northmen there's no
political agenda the woke are furious
there's no diverse cast
and it's extremely masculine it's an
awesome i did go see it i quite enjoyed
it actually i i thought it was really
good um what what are people saying it's
basically hamlet but with vikings yeah
that's what i heard
but that's uh it's where did you see it
uh just local theater okay yeah up in
frederick so i thought it was great
uh
i actually was really uh enthralled
so you know i i determine how how much i
like a movie based on you know a few
factors did i was i was i attuned to the
film the whole time that's a big one
because there are films like really
great scenes where i like whoa
and then something happens and i'll be
like looking around or i'll be like i'm
gonna go to bed what i don't know what's
going on so this movie i didn't take my
eyes off the screen one time i was glued
to it because it's always something cool
happening
i thought it was good i thought it was
good i don't think the story was like a
legendary profound thing but i
remembered everything through it there
were some really cool moments
so how's it doing overall do you think i
don't know but it's cool uh alexander
skarsgard plays a viking berserker it's
really cool
it's brutal now just a question did you
like yellowstone i did not watch it oh
okay yeah i don't know i hear it's good
though i hear it's great yeah yeah
i should watch it though but i like the
northern north and open with 23.5
million is that good it's definitely not
politically correct yellowstone so oh
really when i when i saw the trailers
for the north man i was like i want to
see that like brutal viking film and
it's just
i dig it it's a brutal movie wow yeah
it's cool the cinematography is
incredible too
i thought it was fantastic i i actually
i would say this i would go see it again
it's on my list now yeah
there's very few movies i would go see
twice i would see that one i'm not i'm
not saying that to make you think that
like it's a lord of the rings you know
some epic but it's just really
entertaining so i'm definitely looking
forward to watching it again
and they're saying it's like it's racist
it's all white it's patriarchal it's
alt-right and i'm like dude it's just
like
it's what it was it's a viking movie i
don't know
i watched black panther i thought it was
really good too
like and that was an al mostly black
cast am i supposed to be angry about
this stuff it's just so weird to me man
all right all right
let's see uh
on numbers it says that northmen cost 70
to 90 million to make it's 90 million
dollars and that they've only made about
23 million in the first weekend so they
anticipate not making the money back on
it
but you know that might change they're
saying they don't think they'll make
their money but that's what they get for
spending 90 million on a freaking movie
jeez and it's kind of crazy because it's
a lot of just like outdoors in
scandinavia and like vr or not vr but uh
cg
it's not really are there a lot of high
a-list actors in it or very popular
nicole kidman uh willem dafoe's in it oh
yeah that's 20 million yeah yeah
alexander skarsgard is not that big but
he's a fairly well known play magneto at
some point did he was skarsgard played
magneto is that the same guy no no no
skarsgard was he was in he was in true
blood he was in his most notable role is
he was the male model in zoolander who
sprayed gasoline on
that's a great role all right yeah
i forgot about that scene
that's hysterical the gasoline fight
yeah
motor life than being really really
really ridiculously good looking i want
to watch zoolander now
what is this a school for ants
all right morpheus says twitter now is a
downvote system i'm surprised
really really did they implement that
why did they do that yeah for only some
people though oh
all right laughing dog says only
democrats get to be down voted now with
elon musk's regime laughing dog says
good job with the street meme timmy my
boy very proud of you and your hard work
and shout out to the daily wire for
making this happen we are actually
looking at times square ads though
uh looking at a couple because we have
we've got the tales from the inverted
world book release coming up in a couple
months the new book so we're gonna do
like a big campaign it's gonna be
fantastic building that culture
tales from the inverted world ghosts of
the civil war the coolest thing about it
i think is not like the ghost stories
the ufo bigfoot of the lost gold it's
what i hear from shane cashman our
reporter our writer who's meeting all
these people from the south from georgia
and they're telling him about what went
down in the civil war and it's just like
crazy stuff that you don't hear about
like one story was when you know during
sherman's march to the sea when they
like ransacked everything there was
whiskey pouring from casks into the
street and guys were scooping it up with
their hats and just like trying to drink
it crazy stuff like that yeah cool
stories
yeah and they really hate sherman oh
yeah are you kidding me
she destroyed everything yeah
yeah absolutely brutal
named a tank after him too
yeah
all right let's see we got bradley
markham says i've been watching your
report since 2015 your track record is
impeccable thank you for what you do you
know
it's it's simple like
when i make when i do general reporting
on the facts they tend to be correct
because it you know they'll the
covington kids they come out they lie
about it i do the digging i say here's
what happened i'm right
predictions not as much when i say
because of this here's what i think will
happen
those are up in the air predictions are
very hard right even when they have lots
of information because there's so many
factors that can go into changing the
course of events going forward
and having some
maybe being a little humble okay i found
that in the intelligence community is
very easy for people to report what's
going on to describe things
but they're not very good at predicting
yeah your prediction a public prediction
will also alter the course of whatever
had been happening just by disturbing
the process
yeah well though and that's true i think
over the past couple years especially
i've been reluctant to make predictions
just because of how insane things have
got but i will say this the one
prediction i've gotten more confident in
making is that the media is lying to me
what they're saying to me will turn out
to be a lie that prediction i'm always
comfortable making
all right the one free man says twitter
just reactivated from when i shared the
laptop story interesting also ukraine
government paying farmers to stop
farming us refuses to ship fertilizers
to farms canada declares fertilizer
worst emissions offender more processing
plant fires intentional
perhaps perhaps but it's interesting
that they shut you down over the laptop
and only just released it
some people have says in enron that
right now twitter is burning papers
destroying records destroying code
because they don't want anyone to find
out what's going on well it just goes to
show you because if what he's saying is
true uh the laptop story was proven to
be true a good while before elon musk
purchased twitter
yeah and that code is going to be backed
up elsewhere people are actually
destroying twitter's ip right now by
doing something that code those people
are going to go to federal prison but
the memos the emails that sort of thing
you know people
i think are fairly certain that they
will not be held accountable yeah at the
end of the day
they won't be publicly shamed they won't
be called out and even if someone tries
it'll be very hard to penetrate the the
media controlled environment
they'll just call it fake news over and
over again they don't really need to
cover things up they just need to shame
you for talking about them
all right colonel cornelius cornwall
says i have like 13 plus videos of tim
talking about corn i plan on making a
corn pollation tim please join my corn
cult corn occultia corn be with you corn
be with you we've done amazing things
with corn we've made plastics
fuel
popcorn sounds sounds corny yeah
syrup uh i tried to lower my chair so i
could just sink out of frame when i said
that but it was already too low bar
daxilla says shout out to all the tim
cast members 10 bucks a month is
changing culture thanks tim for being
genuine and transparent we uh we we try
to the greatest degree that we can and
if you become members at timcast.com
just know
we're gonna do more stuff like setting
up billboards calling out the bs and uh
we've got a bunch of other ideas i call
it culture jamming as marketing i didn't
make that up the idea the idea is
am i really going to market this company
by putting up a billboard where it's
like watch the show i mean maybe we
might something like that but what
really works is culture jamming making
something that makes people stop and
think and say hey whoa
challenging the system calling out liars
that's worth way more than putting up an
ad where it's like buy my book
got to do something
all right murph tries diy says sheamus
you need to make tim's rant of elon and
the battle of helm's deep a freedom tune
well now i can't
now he's going to be able to sue me if i
do it what maybe it's it's an
unsolicited pitch
that's right but i'll tell you what
seamus maybe maybe i was gonna but now i
can't maybe maybe you just need to
figure out a way to get those fouchy
roles in these in these cartoons oh man
yeah
he's always gunning for fouchy because
he pays the bills here
maybe we should make a chicken nancy
pelosi for chicken city cartoons
all right logan look says possible
solution to twitter censorship anything
can be posted but every user is required
to tag their post as graphic gore etc
and users also filter out their own set
of tags they don't want to see suspend
those tagging inappropriately
i think what um
minds does is that you have to tag your
content if you don't you get permanently
soft censored meaning they put like a
blur over your pictures over your entire
channel yeah people have to go there and
set it and that's also a great point
granular search so basically you can
blacklist words that you don't want to
see and you can whitelist things that
you want to appear up in your algorithm
that's i think it's a really good way
moving forward
madong
raymond g stanley jr says no crap down
with crap and that's critical race
applied principles completely agree
all right
jeffrey pfaff says staten island gop did
the same thing today to john matlin he
was primarying a useless gop rep what is
that milotakis
we got all of the required signatures
but the establishment gop challenged it
going to court
corruption
not a fan
the jaded kriegsman says tim i like the
idea of
the idea on a boycott but it's better
that people where they can vote in the
vote in for populists in 22 and go vote
in the primaries still vote in the
general but only for populist candidates
and uh right abstain for others yeah
it's a good point you should definitely
vote for the populist if you can because
if there's a hundred jurisdictions where
populist does win then the crony
establishment will have no power power
in the federal government because they
you know assuming they cheated or
whatever or like you know i mean by
booting people out of the primary and
then you got to take what you can get
maybe by 2024 they'll have lost all of
their institutional power
murph tri says what can we do to get
matt walsh to read johnny the walrus to
the cast of chicken city
i don't know how you would keep the
chickens
like watching it's like a yellow card
thing they can come and go also i don't
well maybe we're underestimating how
engaging this story is it's very
engaging chickens could pay attention i
haven't read it do wall versus scare
chickens oh that's a good question
probably but i think the real question
is do pictures of walruses scare
chickens because they might not know the
difference no the real question is does
matt walsh scare chickens matt walsh
does scare chickens yeah chickens are
scared of everything that's why they're
chickens roberto his beard roberto is
getting pretty tough
he's he's he's challenging people you
think he can take matt walsh no but
he'll try not in a one-on-one fight now
walsh would do it to him yeah yeah i
think i think walsh definitely could
beat a rooster could probably beat the
rooster yeah he could beat a rooster
that's my hunch but you're described i
mean you're kind of upselling this
rooster you really what about a goose
though
i don't know if matt walsh could beat a
goose in a
fight excuses
like a big goose i don't know like the
biggest i mean if he if like he had
knowledge backing him up then definitely
not
do you think you could it would do worse
do you think you could beat a uh
a goose derrick
we have five geese at our place oh tell
me about it yeah and they are mean yeah
yeah
okay how close can you get no they they
chase you no jesus okay wouldn't chase
me
no look obviously matt walsh would
destroy a goose matt walsh could defeat
a goose could be a top fight but a gang
of geese no like five i think you'd have
to run i'd mess every one of those geese
up yeah what what what about what
remember that meme fight one horse-sized
duck or a hundred duck-sized horses
i think you gotta go with the small
horses they're more docile oh man we
just don't get behind a horse there was
there was a hysterical study and i can't
remember where it was from but it was
basically a survey done comparing the
results between men and women when they
asked them which animals they could
defeat in a fight it's really good oh
man maybe we'll pull it up on the after
show
i think i'm not easier now you haven't
told me yeah yeah exactly you guys are
gonna have to see the results two two
not into the after show
all right matthew miller says good to
hear the spirit of dave smith speaking
through sheamus that tax tax talk on
labor versus gas sounds familiar cheers
all his dave smith said that well good
for him
you mean you're not gonna acknowledge
that you ripped off i stole it from dave
you know i was watching look all look we
need to roll back the state we spy on
all of our own citizens our prisons are
flooded with non-violent drug offenders
if you want to know who we're going to
go to war with next look at who we're
funding right now original sheamus
coughlin quote very original yeah
all right
lackles says
we built chicken city on bach and crow
well okay
it's a song
darius harvey says do you guys have an
app yet almost
we almost have an app we're starting
with ios and then we're going to do
android and it takes time because
oh man things take too much time they're
expensive so um
become a member at tipgus.com
orangered says what happens to cast
castle once you move to the new hq there
will be some production stuff still
happening here
uh i don't know about the vlog though we
may have to move that to free damastan
but then what is the name cast castle
and not free damastan i don't know
we've got really cool uh updates on the
on the the foundation's been laid
they're gonna be doing the building soon
we're gonna be building it's gonna look
so wacky it's gonna be amazing we got
crazy plans i don't want to release them
just yet but we're gonna one thing we
are planning on doing the internals of
the new uh workspace is going to be
fully skateable
so like there will be a picnic bench for
to sit up sit and work at
angle iron grind bars you can skate on
it you can do whatever there's going to
be a stage it's also going to be a part
of a fun box like a multi-use skate
obstacle and the the flat can open up to
a foam pit
the bar where you can go get something
to drink or cook food totally skateable
angle iron skate light all that good
stuff the whole thing it's gonna be epic
so during the work day people are
working and then once work is done
people will throw it on their boards put
on their blades grab their scooter or
bike and then they're gonna be grinding
on all their work equipment that sounds
like a good tourist uh location for
people to come set up tours
instead of lodging you know visitors
that would be really fun and then we'll
just you know my goal is in 10 years to
have massive skyscrapers in the middle
of west virginia where people are going
to be like what is going on hey hey
we're but that means we're going to have
tons of new people coming in bringing
new jobs and it's going to be it's going
to be really when my 5 year old and 9
year old hear about this they're going
to say that's where i want to work yeah
well we already have a skate park in
this house
in the in we have in the basement and we
have one in the garage
so the new space is 7 500 square feet
31 feet tall 25 on the sides with the 34
30 31 foot at the center because the
pitch
we're going to have the studio very much
like we do now but it's going to be on
the second floor it's going to have one
wall all glass so you can see the whole
you know interior of the building i hate
to bring this up but what's osha say
about that no it's all
fun yeah yeah i mean it's it's actually
nothing particularly crazy relative to
what a lot of companies already do when
i went like like fusion's office had
that already the the mezzanine was like
overlooking the entirety of the
warehouse building with all the people
working on the bottom ours is just a
particularly smaller version of it so
the the real issue is
how you segment space for who and what
work and like how it works for insurance
but i think we're able to navigate it
just fine you know so certain space is
allotted to certain elements of the
business and not to the others and
there's different companies that have
different portions and stuff like that
we'll build some stuff outside as well
uh it's gonna be a lot of fun we have
this gigantic like 15-foot mound of dirt
now for when they excavated
we'll maybe build something i don't know
all right yeah underground tunnels habit
house earth ships yeah
all right but uh hopefully it'll get
done yeah castle is also a verb so cast
castle would be like the moving of the
king
all right ev style says still looking
for sandwich prospects sent an email to
spin the ufo really interested in making
sandwiches for you guys
uh donut and deli for life i think we're
going to do a coffee shop first
because we looked over the cost and we
were like coffee's probably the safest
and fastest and easiest way to go and
there's a lot of interesting ideas we
could do for it
you know just undercut starbucks and put
them next to them i uh i've been
inundated with
people who are excited to make
sandwiches for us so you guys are all
displacing me i'm just kidding no i have
too many sandwich offers and we'll
figure it out well what we need is
someone who knows how to run a sandwich
shop we don't need someone who's like
i've made a sandwich before we need
someone who's like i know the equipment
the machinery someone has actually
managed it in fact we need someone who's
probably run one and then we could do it
but you know we'll see
uh so let's uh
wait what
i can't read that super chat so i'm
gonna keep going and uh
september thompson says the chicken
party needs an animated tim yelling
chicken party well here's the idea
we have an idea for the ultimate chicken
party which is we just recorded the
chicken city theme song
and so what will happen is if ten
chicken parties happen in one day an
ultimate party happens where me and ian
walk in on both sides and ian's banging
the tambourine while we're both playing
and singing the chicken city theme song
that's so good
so good
raymond g stanley jr says proud of views
don't let him down for the line my
friends if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have that bonus segment members only
coming up at 11 p.m and as a member you
are keeping our journalists employed we
hired a new journalist we're hiring more
and
you will allow us to do things like buy
billboards and challenge the system so
it's greatly appreciated you can follow
us at tim cast irl basically everywhere
you can follow me at tim cast do you
want to shout anything out derek
i'd just like to thank everyone for
letting me join you tonight i think this
is you know very quick witted and a
conversation good insights very agile
thinking uh some good comedy oh thank
you good impersonations and i really
enjoyed it i'd love to be back i'd like
to bring my kids absolutely to see the
compound this is fantastic we got a
great gig going here when's the election
happening july 19th and we need a good
turnout i think the more people that
turn out the better because we got to
get the base out and we got to go after
the establishment candidates and
challenge them right on do you have a
website people could check out vote
derrickharvey.com
and you can also find me vote derek
harvey on facebook
right on
i am seamus coughlin i do cartoons on a
youtube channel called freedom tunes we
release a new cartoon every thursday
we're working on one about disney losing
its special privileges and one about
musk buying twitter in fact there's a
good amount of material there we might
do more than one on that topic go over
there subscribe hit the notification
bell and thank you so much for watching
ian crossland guys thanks for coming out
uh check me out and crossland.net if you
want to get in touch somehow and come
over timcast.com and check out the after
show see you later yeah i just wanted to
say if you do go to vote for derek
harvey dot com there's a really cute
picture of him and his little family on
their tractor which is incredible and i
also wanted to say people have been
yelling at me and telling me that the my
pillow guy is back and that the babylon
b is back i haven't seen that the
babylon b is actually back the mike
lindell account that is back is not a
lot of fake accounts being made right
now so watch out always do your due
diligence and make sure you're spreading
the truth making sure that everybody's
on the correct page you guys can follow
me on twitter we're also going down at
sarah patch lids as well as minds.com
and at sourpatchlids.me yeah a lot of
fake accounts that people don't know
this the cast account is actually me it
is yeah stay away from that one yeah i'm
actually not even on twitter it's not
even there so every time he's trending
it's it's actually
sheamus wishes he was me on twitter what
i've got 1.1 million followers well i
have
no i actually i actually i gained a
bunch of followers on my account yeah
like 20 000 today or whatever that's
because russia heard musk bought twitter
and now they're sending the bots in
that's it all right everybody head over
to timcast.com become a member and we
will see you all shortly
you